Well, we just saw the code for processing these tokens,
and we know that it went to a bit of trouble
to store the beginning position, lexps,
and then the ending position,
but then--phwoomp--subtract out 9.
So this is way too much.
We went to a lot of trouble to drop
<script type"--blah, blah, blah--so this one doesn't match.
Similarly, this one doesn't match.
This one looks perfect! It has stripped out the tag at the beginning
and the tag at the end.
This one still has the tag at the end, so it's not right.
In the particular example we're using,
the Satasai or Bihari Satsai
are 700 verses from the 17th century.
They're written in Hindi
and they cover topics from morality to devotion, to love.
Good stuff!